Cats.
You know them, you love them.
Or at least, I do.
But whatever you feel about cats, they’re
a bit of a scientific mystery.
No one is totally sure whether the common
house cat is really a domestic breed distinct
from its wild ancestors.
Since the cat genome was first sequenced,
albeit incompletely, in 2007, we know all
cats can be traced back to the Near Eastern
wildcat that still lives in Israel, Saudi
Arabia, and other Middle Eastern countries.
Now, a team of geneticists have taken their
love of cats to a whole new level.
They studied DNA found in the remains of 209
ancient cats that lived between 15,000 years
ago and the 18th century.
The results give some insight into how cats
conquered the world… before the Internet.
Right off the bat, the team knew they had
something interesting on their hands.
They found a 9,500 year old tomb in Cyprus
that contained cat remains alongside human
remains, and they also found remains in Egyptian
tombs from 6,000 years ago -- because those
Egyptians were really fond of felines!
The researchers expanded their study to include
cat remains found in burial sites across Europe,
the Middle East and Africa.
They focused specifically on mitochondrial
DNA.
Unlike nuclear DNA that is found in the nucleus
of most cells, mitochondrial DNA is found
in sub-compartments outside the nucleus.
And this type of DNA only contains genetic
information passed down from momma.
In cats, the team found a mitochondrial lineage
between Middle Eastern wild cats and early
farming communities in the eastern Mediterranean,
so it looks like cats spread pretty easily
among early farming communities.
The team suspects they were probably drawn
by the mice who were in turn drawn to the
farms by grain stores, and the humans probably
kept them around to manage the rodent population.
The same mitochondrial strain was also found
linking cats from Egypt between the 4th century
BCE and 4th century CE to cats in Bulgaria,
Turkey, and sub-Saharan Africa.
So farm-based was one wave of cat expansion.
The second was by boat.
Again, the mitochondrial DNA connection was
found in analyzed cat remains from a Viking
site in northern Germany.
This suggests cats traveled the world with
sailors and Vikings for the same reason farmers
kept them around: to help keep rodent populations
in check.
The full cat genome was only mapped in 2014,
and this study is the largest yet on ancient
cat DNA.
Cat geneticists want to do further testing
with nuclear DNA to answer the lingering question
of cat domestic and wild cat interbreeding,
all in the name of helping us understand our
favourite furry friends.